pendant très longtemps pendant des
siècles et des siècles le pouvoir
central de l'église catholique a éprouvé
toutes les difficultés à se dégager de
la gang du pouvoir temporel
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le moment
historique est venu le vatican ces 44
hectares le vatican s'est aucune
division
aujourd'hui en europe occidentale la
vieille grand mère catholique quand même
singulièrement fatigué époustouflé au
sens au sens propre notamment après la
pandémie on sait qu'aujourd'hui un tiers
des pratiquants ne sont pas revenus dans
les églises on sait que les ressources
financières chutent
on sait que la corrosion en disons de la
sécularisation touche profondément
l'europe que les sorties d'église sont
très importantes et donc le moment est
venu aujourd'hui et c'est ça que le pape
françois a senti le moment est venu
aujourd'hui pour les catholiques de
renouer avec le choeur de l'évangile de
renouer avec le message du christ et
c'est bien ça que à travers l'ensemble
de ces textes et à travers l'ensemble de
ses gestes
c'est ça que le pape françois essaye de
mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui
[Musique]